Tonight is a
tricky subject
and
I'm almost nervous to approach it. But
we are going to power through and it's
going to get worse before it gets
better.
So we might as well just dive in and say
some of the things that the book of
Revelation says. You know, we are always
so scared to say what the book of
revelation says.
But then on the other hand, I am
personally very grateful that it does
say these things because I myself have
been trapped in many of these
deceptions.
And I'm so grateful to God for having
said these things so that we can make
decisions to sever the ties that bind us
to all these strange winds of doctrine
which we take so for granted because we
don't know anything else. The simplicity
of knowing Jesus Christ and him
crucified escapes many of us. And if
only we knew what a friend we have and
how approachable he is and how easy it
is to be in contact with him, we would
save ourselves
many a tear and many a trouble. Well,
who is this beast from the bottomless
pit and where do we read about it? Well,
we finished last night up to the end of
chapter nine. Now logically we should go
into chapter 10
but I will reserve chapter 10 for a
little bit later because there are two
sides to a story. The one is the
apostasy as it grows. And we started
that last night. And we show how showed
how spiritual darkness increased on this
earth and how
a star fell from heaven and smoke
started coming out of the bottomless
pit.
That means satanic teachings were
starting to emanate and take control of
the earth. Tonight we're going to go a
little bit further and we'll see what
eventually is the culmination of these
things that come from the bottomless pit
and it will develop into a beast that
comes from the bottomless pit. Now what
is a beast? Well again we have to ask
the Bible and in Daniel chapter 7 a
beast is very clearly defined as a king
of a king or a kingdom. It's a kingdom.
So here is a political entity that is
manifesting itself. So in other words,
the false teaching have become so
widespread that they have infiltrated
into a political system and have become
world doctrine if you like. That's scary
legislated world doctrine
in its fullness.
We had not seen it at this stage when it
appears, but it will grow into a
worldwide phenomenon.
And that's the scary bit. And the
question is, who's behind it all? And
that question we also want to answer
tonight. Revelation chap 11. We're
skipping 10 because that's the
counterparts and we'll be dealing with
that a little bit later.
And there was given me a reed like unto
a rod. And the angel stood saying, "Rise
and measure the temple of God."
You know, when you measure something,
you're seeing whether it measures up.
Isn't that so? The Bible says, "We are
the temple of the living God."
So, do we measure up?
Measure the temple of God and the altar
and them that worship therein. So just
like we had a numbering, so now we have
a measuring.
But the court which is without the
temple, leave out and measure it not.
For it is given unto the Gentiles and
the holy city, they shall tread under
foot. They will trample upon the truth
of God and upon the salvation in Christ
which is typified in the sanctuary.
Everything in the sanctuary is typical
of Christ. The door, the gateway where
you came in is a representative of
Christ. The door, the altar of burnt
offering is a representation of the
cross. The lamb that was slain, behold
the lamb of God that taketh away the
sins of the world. The labor that
washes, he's the one that washes away
our sins. You must be born by water and
the spirit.
If you go into the first chamber, Jesus
is the light of the world. Jesus is the
bread of the presence. Jesus is the
bread from heaven. He is the incense
that makes us acceptable through his
merit to God. If you go into the final
chamber, he's the lawgiver. He shields
us from the condemnation of the law
through his mercy. Wow. Everything's
there in the sanctuary. It's a beautiful
message. So, here is the story of
salvation in Christ which will be
trampled under by certain gentile forces
and this will be done for 40 and two
months. Now that's a prophetic time
again and uh it would be interesting to
know what this entails and of course it
is a quote from the book of Daniel
chapter 7 where all the attributes of
the antichrist are given including the
fact that he reigns for this period
and I will give power unto my two
witnesses
and they shall prophesy that is preach
1,23
score days clothed in sackcloths. Now
that's what we call Hebrew parallelism.
You say something in one way and you
repeat it in another way. So the first
42 months is followed by 1,260
days. And in prophetic terms, they're
the same period. 42 prophetic months.
The prophetic month had 30 days.
42 * 30 is 1,260
days. 1,260
days. A day for a year. 1,260
years. We will come to that later. Is a
period when the sanctuary will be
trampled underfoot and God's people as
well. Now, who are these two witnesses
that will stand up for what God has to
say? Well, these are the two olive trees
and the two candlesticks, the lights
standing before the God of the earth.
And if any man will hurt them, take note
of this. If any man will hurt them, fire
proceeds out of their mouth and devour
their enemy. And if any man will hurt
them, he must in this manner be killed.
Don't mess with these olive trees. Don't
mess with these two candlesticks.
Well, would be interesting to know who
they are, isn't that so?
Well, let's first have a look at this
prophetic time period. So there's a key
to the year day principle and we find it
as the period of reign of the little
horned power in Daniel chapter 7 where
it says they shall be given into his
hand that's the saints of the most high
for a time times and the dividing of
times that is three and a half prophetic
years or 42 months or 1,260
days. We'll see the parallels in a
moment. And calculating the length of
this prophetic period is greatly
simplified if we note these simple
points. A time was a year. Some of the
newer translations will just say three
and a half years.
That's 360 days. You can see Daniel
chapter 4:16 and 11:13 margin in the
authorized version of the Bible, the
King James. prophetic time or year had
days. A day means a year or a time means
a year in Bible prophecy. You'll find
that in the authorized version. So, we
add it up and it comes to 1,260
days. And you can look up Numbers 14:34
and Ezekiel 4:6 where it says, "I have
appointed thee each day for a year."
Proof of the pudding is always in the
eating.
So these are then actually 1,260
literal years.
Now here are some other regions where
you will find these texts. Daniel uses
the the terminology in chapter 12:7 a
time times and a half. Revelation 11:24
and 2 months. Revelation 11:360
days. Revelation 126 1260 days.
Revelation 12:14 times and half a time.
Revelation 13:540 and two months all
referring to the same time period.
I'll show them to you again in a little
while. Now, 10 kingdoms
of Rome that that are emanated from Rome
were established in AD476.
And in Daniel, it says that this power
that would control or have control over
God's people would arise after the
establishment of the 10 kingdoms. In
other words, after western Rome was
divided into 10.
Well,
this period is very interesting because
after this period in AD 538,
the papal rule commenced according to
the Justinian decree which said that the
papacy would be the corrector of
heretics and that he would be the head
of all the churches. So you had a church
state scenario. Now, if you add to that
date 1,260
years, you get to an interesting date,
1798.
Let's look at these time periods again.
Daniel 7:25, a time, times, and the
dividing of times. Daniel 12:7, a time,
times, and a half. Revelation 11:2, 40
and 2 months. Revelation 11:3, 1260
days. Revelation 126, 1260 days.
Revelation 12:14 time times and half a
time. Revelation 13:540 and 2 months. Do
you think God is serious about telling
you about this time period?
It seems like it. Eh, he wants us to
know something about this time period.
And we can find out from the Bible that
they mean the same thing through Hebrew
parallelism. For example, in the book of
Revelation, it will say a woman, a
wilderness, 1,260
days. In another verse, it will say a
woman, a weren 42 months. In another
place, it will say 3 and a half years.
And so, you can see that they apply to
the same thing. A very, very important
prophecy.
Now in 1798 something very interesting
happened. Bertiier
the French general marched into Rome
under orders of Napoleon and he arrested
the pope and declared the papacy at an
end. Declared it at an end. Now it is
important to note that the papacy was a
political entity. And if you take the
definition of Daniel chapter 7 that a
political entity is called a beast
power. The kingdoms you saw the four
beasts or four kingdoms which shall
arise upon the earth. Then if you end
that political power
well then that beast dies.
Now it's interesting that to this
particular power there's another
interesting verse in revelation which
says it seemed to have a mortal wound
but the mortal wound was healed. In
other words, it dies but it comes back
and this power was reinstated as a
political entity in 1929
when Mussolini granted the papal states
and political autonomy to the Vatican
again. So there was a beast, a
political, religio, political entity. It
received a mortal wound over here and
yet it rose and received it back again.
And then there are some interesting
things in the book of Revelation about
this. So let's look at this mortal
wound. On the 21st of February 1798,
Pope Pas the 6th was defroth thrown by
Napoleon. His ring was torn off from his
finger. that is the symbol of his power
and he died in exile. So there was a
mortal wound. By December 1804, Pope
Pius witnessed uh Napoleon crown himself
emperor. Here was now a po pope without
a political entity to rule. It had been
taken away. 1808 Napoleon took the
Vatican state. So he confiscated the
entire state of the Vatican.
1848 Miniia attacks Rome and Pope Pius
the 9th he's exiled he's restored in
1850 but he had lost all the papal
states so there was now no longer a
political entity here was a mortal wound
and the timing amazing 538
he ascends the throne under the
protection of the Eastern Roman Empire
under the emperor himself and assumes
the authority ity of the Justinian
decree. 1,260
prophetic days later,
the political power comes to an end.
Interesting.
Immediately, Napoleon
reinstated religious freedom in 1806 on
the 30th of May. And so we had a power
that ruled over God's people for a
period of time politically dictating to
other political forces what they should
do with denters. You see Rome never put
anyone to death. Never. The Inquisition
was run by the Jesuits and uh later by
the Dominicans.
But the Jesuits were the original
inquisitors.
They would find someone guilty and hand
him over to the state who put him to
death.
That's how it worked. Now, who are these
two witnesses that witnessed in
sackcloth during this time period? My
two witnesses, these are the two olive
trees and the two candlesticks standing
before the God of the earth. By the way,
did the Roman church suppress the
scriptures during its period of reign?
Yes or no? Yes. I was a Catholic. It was
a mortal sin to read the Bible. It was a
mortal sin. Later on after 1962,
that was rescended and changed. And
we'll come to why.
Very interesting stuff
in a subsequent lecture. So, who are
these two witnesses? Could they perhaps
be the scriptures, the Old and the New
Testament? Is it possible? Well, let's
go to Zechariah and see if we can find
an answer. Zechariah 4:1.
And the angel that talked with me came
again and walked me, wked me as a man
that is waked out of his sleep. And he
said unto me, "What seeest thou?" And I
said, "I have looked, and behold, a
candlestick." Now here you have a
candlestick all of gold with a bowl upon
the top of it and his seven lamps there
on and seven pipes to the seven lamps
which are upon the top thereof and two
olive trees. There we have the same
symbols. So Revelation draws on the
symbolism in Zechariah here. And
remember that the power that ruled for
1,260
years as a political entity having
political muscle over everyone that
desented as a heretic for example
is involved. So we'll look at Zechariah
and see if we can find some other images
here that might be interesting. So we
find the candlesticks that are mentioned
in Revelation. We also find the two
olive trees that are mentioned in
Revelation. By it, one upon the right
side of the bowl and the other upon the
left side thereof.
Verse four. So I answered and spoke to
the angel that talked with me, saying,
"What are these, my lord?" Well, that's
what we're just asking. So maybe we can
get an answer. And the angel that talked
with me answered and said to me,
"Knowest thou not what these be?" And I
said, "No, my lord, just like we would
say, what are they?" And then he
answered and spoke unto me, saying,
"This is the word of the Lord unto
Zerubbable, saying," and then he says,
"Whatever it is there is to say." So
what are these
olive trees and the candlesticks?
The word of God. The word of God. So
this word of God was prophesying in
sackcloth. In other words, suppressed
for 1,260
days. You know, when the reformation
started printing the Bible, they started
using the Gutenber press and they just
marched in there and they smashed it and
they burnt every Bible that was being
printed and they tried to destroy it
with every means at their disposal
without much success. Well, later on
they wrote their counter version which
is known as the Jesuit Bible. We'll come
to that later.
Verse 11. Then answered I and said unto
him, "And what are these two olive trees
upon the right side of the candlestick,
and upon the left side thereof?" And I
answered again, and I said unto him,
"What be these two olive branches which
through the two golden pipes empty the
golden oil out of themselves?" Then he
answered me and said, "No, thou not what
these be?" And I said, "No, my lord."
Then he said these are the two anointed
ones anointed with power from God. In
other words, the whole through the Holy
Spirit this message of God, this word of
God was to be preached to the world
whether suppressed or not that stand by
the Lord of the whole earth.
And then I turned and I lifted up my
eyes and I looked. Now what is he going
to see? He's going to see what it's all
about. A flying roll. Now, what's a
flying roll? That's a scroll. That's the
word of God was in a scroll. So, he sees
the word of God flying through the air.
What's that a symbol of? Taking the
message to the world. So, this is what
it's all about. It's about the word of
God. And he said unto me, "What seeest
thou?" And I answered, "I see a flying
roll. The length thereof is," and he
gives the length in cubits. And he said
unto me, "This is the curse that goes
forth over the whole earth. For everyone
that stealth shall be cut off." These
are the warnings of God.
As on this side according to it, and
everyone that swearth shall be cut off
on that side according to it. I will
bring it forth, says the Lord of Hosts,
and it shall enter into the house of the
thief,
and into the house of him that swearth
falsely by my name, and it shall remain
in the midst of his house, and shall
consume it with the timber thereof, and
the stones thereof. Okay. So, the word
of God will convict whether it's
suppressed or not. Is that right?
Basically, what it says,
let's read on because Zechariah gets
interesting. Then the angel that talked
with me went forth. Remember Revelation
11 is quoting from Zechariah from these
very verses. And we can get more
information. What was that I said in the
beginning? To the law and to the
testimony. So now we're digging in the
testimony to see what other prophets had
said that would be in harmony with
what's going on over here.
Lift up now thy eyes and see this that
goes forth. And I said, "What is this?"
And he said, "This is an epha." Wow. Now
it gets interesting. That goes forth.
Now what is an epha?
An epha was a measure.
It was a standard measure wherein you
would measure flour. For example, now in
the book of revelation, wasn't there
some measuring going on? Yes or no? Aha.
So here we have another measuring going
on. We have the standard of measurement.
Obviously the standard for whatever is
right and what is wrong. But here is an
interesting standard that has set itself
up. What is this? And I said this is an
epha that goes forth and he said
moreover this is their resemblance
through all the earth. This standard is
what you will see throughout the earth.
And behold, there was lifted up a talent
of lead. You see, the epha had a lid on
it, a heavy lid.
And uh this lid here was a heavy lid. It
was made of lead. So he lifted up this
lead lid and he looked inside the air,
which is the standard of measurement.
And what does he see inside?
A woman that siteth in the midst of the
air file. Well, that's interesting.
What's a woman in the Bible?
It's a church.
It's a church. So, there is an apostate
church on this earth and there is a
righteous church on this earth. And in
this one, there sits a woman. So there
is a standard ana that is being set up
by a church. Is that logical?
That sits in the midst of the epha. And
he said this is wickedness.
So this is contrary to what the scroll
had been saying. The scroll in the
beginning had said I will convict you by
my word. If you steal you will know
about. If you do this that and the other
my word will convict you. But here is
another standard on earth and it is
controlled by a different church and
it's a wicked one. It says it's
wickedness and he cast it in the midst
of the earth and he cast the weight of
lead upon the mouth thereof. So this
woman was revealed for a time and then
the lid was put back. Oops.
Now that's interesting. Did the
reformation reveal a standard that was
not biblical? Yes or no? Sure did. And
the lid was lifted up and everybody
could see it. What did the reformation
call Rome?
Blatantly said Antichrist. And then
closed. What's the Reformation say
today? Publicly, officially by all their
sinners.
What did the Lutheran senate decide?
1994, I think was the date, if I am
correct, she may no longer be called
Antichrist. Calvinists decided the same.
All of them decided the same thing. So
the lid goes back on.
Then lifted up mine eyes and looked and
beheld, there came two women.
And the wind was in their wings, for
they had wings like the wings of a
stalk. Oh, that's bad news. That's bad
news. Because you see, the stalk is an
unclean bird. And a bird in the Bible
here is a symbol of the Holy Spirit. So
here are two groups which will now
through the workings of a false spirit
lift up this standard with the other
woman in it between heaven and earth.
And they said to the angel that talked
with me whether do these bear the epha
this standard and he said to me to build
it a house in the land of Sha
that's Babylon.
and it shall be established and set
there upon her own base. Wow. What
Zachchariah is saying
is that another standard will reign on
this earth. The standard will be set by
a church.
Everybody will have re a knowledge that
it was wickedness. It was revealed but
the wickedness is being covered up. And
then two powerful church groups, the
Bible calls them the dragon and the
false prophet powers will come and lift
up this standard and say there it is.
And the Babylonian Empire will be reborn
in spiritual sense on this earth with a
standard that replaces God's standard.
Does that make sense? Scary. Is it going
to happen? Well, let's see what the rest
of Revelation has to say on the issue.
The word of God. Now, we've had a
background from the place in the Bible
where Revelation takes its imagery and
tells us what's going on. The word of
God, Revelation 11:6, these
have power to shut heaven that it rain
not. Does the word of God have power to
do that? Absolutely. Did Elijah do it?
Elijah prayed under the instigation of
God and said, "It will not rain three
and a half years." And it didn't rain
three and a half years. Interesting that
this prophetic power reigns three and a
half prophetic years. No rain. What does
that mean spiritually?
A barrenness for the word of God.
So they made war against the word of
God. Not in the days of their prophecy.
So there was spiritual darkness. We've
dealt with that already. And have power
of the waters to turn them to blood and
to smite the earth with all plagues as
often as they will. Wow. Bad news. If
you take the word of God away, you're in
trouble. And when they shall have
finished their testimony in sackcloth,
the beast that ascendeth out of the
bottomless pits
shall make war against them. Now, when
will they have finished their testimony
in sackcloth?
After the 1,260 days. Well, if that
prophecy is correct, then that brings us
to about 1798.
And in that time period,
a power will start emerging on earth
which will make it its business to
destroy the word of God.
Interesting. So after 1798,
a power will emerge that will make it
its business to destroy the word of God.
And this beast descendeth out of the
bottomless pit.
Now, who was in the bottomless pit
before? Well, the star that fell from
heaven made smoke come out of the
bottomless pit. His false doctrines
wafting across the earth. And now it is
being established to the point of
authority. So this is Satan's kingdom
growing on the earth. But remember, God
is just watching it and permitting it
and telling you about it.
And he shall make war against them and
shall overcome them and kill them.
So there must be something happening
where the word of God is officially
rejected.
But this is a greater involvement. There
is going to be the rise of a kingdom
that officially wants to obliterate the
word of God. And their dead bodies shall
lie in the streets of the great city
which is spiritually
called Sodom and Egypt where also our
Lord was crucified. Now our Lord was not
crucified in Sodom and he was not
crucified in Egypt. So only in the form
of his people can he be crucified. Now
is there perhaps a little typology that
we could grab onto here? Is there
anything that happened round about this
time period 1798 round about there where
there was an attack on words God on the
go on the word
that was a mixup of words. I'll repeat
that where there was an attack on the
word of God in a place where God's
people had been sacrificed if you like
killed murdered for the sake of their
faith. So Christ being crucified again
in the form of his people. Is there a
country that did that? Actually there is
very interesting country and that
country was France
and uh they did exactly this. They are
enacting a little miniature in uh the
book great controversy. There's a
beautiful statement on this issue. Let's
read it. The great city in whose streets
the witnesses are slain and where their
dead bodies lie is spiritually Egypt. Of
all nations presented in the Bible,
Egypt most boldly denied the existence
of the living God and resisted his
commands. No monarch ever ventured upon
more open and high-handed rebellion
against the authority of heaven than did
the king of Egypt. When the message was
brought to him by Moses in the name of
the Lord, Pharaoh proudly answered, "Who
is Jehovah that I should obey his voice
to let Israel go? I know not Jehovah,
neither will I let Israel go." This is
open rebellion against the word of God.
goes on to say, "This is atheism then
and the nation represented by Egypt
would give voice to the similar denial
of claims of the living garden would
manifest a like spirit of unbelief and
defiance."
The great city is also compared
spiritually to Sodom. The corruption of
Sodom in breaking the law of God was
especially manifested in lentiousness.
In other words, you know, sexual
depravity if you like. And this sin was
also to be preeminent characteristic of
the nation that should fulfill the
specification of the scripture. Now I
can go along with that. That's pretty
fascinating stuff.
Where also our Lord was crucified. This
specification of the prophecy was also
fulfilled by France. I agree with that.
In no land had the spirit of enmity
against Christ been more strikingly
displayed. In no country had the truth
encountered more bitter and cruel
opposition in the persecution which
France had visited upon the confessors
of the gospel. She had crucified Christ
in the person of his disciples. I concur
with this. I would like to go even
further and say that France is just the
very beginning the kernel of the rise of
the kingdom of Lucifer.
And I will prove that as we go along
with help from many quotes
and we will see what was set up there
which is going to rule the whole world
today
and it affects you and me directly. This
is not just history. This is history in
application.
This is the famous Jacco Bean hat that
was worn by the French revolutionaries.
They wore the Jaccoin hat. Now what the
Jaccoin hat means I will be dealing with
in a later lecture. Actually it's the
hat of Mitra. It's Mitraism sun worship.
But never mind. We'll come to that
later. Revelation 11:7. And when they
shall have finished their testimony, the
beast that ascendeth out of the
bottomless pit shall make war against
them. Now what happened in France is the
forerunner.
Take note. What happened in France is
the forerunner of what will happen in
the entire world. Scary.
And shall overcome them and kill them.
Did France after the French Revolution
make war against the word of God?
Revelation 11:9. And they of the people
and kindreds and tongues and nations
shall see their dead bodies three days
and a half. I another prophetic time.
Three and a half days would be three and
a half years. And shall not suffer their
dead bodies to put in the graves. Well,
from November 10, 1793 to June 1797,
they did that. They banned the Bible
officially
by government decree. They banned the
Bible.
And they that dwell upon the earth shall
rejoice over them. The two witnesses,
the Old and the New Testament, make
merry shall send gifts to one another.
Did the French do that? Yes, they
actually did that because these two
prophets, the Bible, had tormented them
that dwelt on the earth. In actual fact,
they only believed that this Bible had
tormented them, the people. But somebody
else actually believed that this Bible
was a tormenting power. And I will show
you tonight who that power is that made
war against the Bible.
And after three days and a half, the
spirit of life from God entered into
them, and they stood up on their feet,
and great fear fell upon them which saw
them. Did it destroy the Bible? No.
After this event which was just the
beginning of this great attack on the
word of God, power came into the word of
God and the Bibles went all over the
world. All the great Bible societies
were started after this day and the
Bible was put into every hand that
wanted it in the whole world. This
infuriated the beast from the bottomless
pit
to such an extent that it changed it
tactics of war. And we'll be dealing
with that in two lectures called the
battle of the Bibles and changing the
word. Don't miss those lectures. They're
coming up and they are powerful. If
you're angry with me tonight, come back
anyway. Okay? Even if you're angry, it's
okay. You can be angry with me, but come
anyway.
So this word of God stood up and
preached with power hereafter. But the
war wasn't over. It just began. They
heard a great voice from heaven saying
unto them, "Come up hither." And they
ascended up to heaven in a cloud, and
their enemies beheld them. And the
enemy, I'll tell you, hates the word of
God. And the same hour there was a great
earthquake, and a tenth part of the city
fell. obviously referring to this
spiritual city Babylon if you like was
shaken by this resurgence of power in
the word of God and so Satan redoubled
his efforts to crunch it again
thereafter
and in the earthquake was slain of men
7,000 again that is a symbolic number
and the remnant were frighted and gave
glory to the God of heaven
notice Notice the second woe is passed
and behold the third woe cometh quickly.
A woe is something
that makes it impossible for the people
to find truth.
The first woe was the destruction
physically of the original Christian
areas
through powers that were against Christ.
This woe is now a spiritually darkening
of all knowledge pertaining to God by
this power who makes war on the word of
God. What happened in the French
Revolution? Let's just see how it
fulfilled these prophecies.
This was the storming of the Bastile.
And of course at this very event, the
whole political structure in the world
changed. Whereas before you had monarchs
ruling, now you have democracies and
democracies are going to rule
everywhere.
And that sounds very good. And we will
see exactly what is behind all of these
things later. So Louis the 16th, well he
lost his head literally and his head was
held up before a cheering crowd as he
went to the guillotine.
and his wife Marian Twuinette. Did they
have mercy on her? No. Her head was put
on a steak and held up to a cheering
crowd.
And then they took a prostitute, excuse
the picture, but this is what they
actually did with open breasts and they
called her Liberty.
They made her a goddess. Liberty
leading.
Now we read again what happened here in
the book Great Controversy tells it to
us quite beautifully. When the goddess
was brought into the convention, the
orator took her by the hand. Turning to
the assembly, he said, "Mortals, cease
to tremble before the powerless thunders
of a god whom your fears have created."
Wow. This is a public assembly.
Henceforth knowledge no divinity but
reason.
Can you imagine that? I offer you its
noblest and purest image. If you must
have idols, sacrifice only to such as
this. Fall before the august senate of
freedom, veil of reason. So here was a
power that had taken away the word of
God and replaced it with a goddess of
reason. But fortunately Jesus told us
ahead of time that it would happen.
And this means that uh this goddess of
reason takes the place of Jesus Christ
only in appearance. The goddess after
being embraced by the president was
mounted on a magnificent car and
conducted amidst an immense crowd to the
cathedral of NRAAM.
So it was made official to take the
place of the deity.
Then she was elevated on the high altar
and received the adoration of all
present. So the government adored this
lady. This is how it was done. She was
taken through the streets. She was put
onto a cart. She had a sun symbol and it
said goddess of reason
over there. And she was enthroned in
NRAM. And that which they believed
Christianity had stood for was swept
away by the legislature. And the Old
Testament and the New Testaments were
burnt and all religious books were burnt
on a funeral p.
And a new law replaced God's law.
Can we replace God's law?
I don't think so. That scroll that flies
through heaven, the word of God,
condemns us of right and of wrong,
measures us according to its standard
irrespective of whether another
institute raises up another standard.
Right or wrong? Yes.
And so tonight we will see how this
battle continued. How one standard was
laid aside and how mankind adopted
another standard. And may God help us to
choose between standards.
We continue the story.
What happens when you replace God's
standard with human standards?
Human standards are made to look good,
but obviously they have their problems.
Well, during the French Revolution, a
new standard for mankind evolved. And
this standard was termed the manifesto
of human rights.
By the way, if you listen to the media
today, do you hear God's law, God's law,
God's law, or do you hear human rights,
human rights, human rights? What do you
hear?
>> You hear human rights. Now, isn't it
fascinating
that the French published their first
manifest of human rights in this form?
Isn't that fascinating?
As two tablets of stone, what does that
actually represent?
The law of God. Here was man putting
down another law. This is fascinating
stuff. Oh, there's so much symbolism in
this. It's way too big to deal with this
with this tiny slide. I will put it up
in another lecture in all its glorious
detail and show you the symbolism behind
it. I'll just mention
just one. This here, a bundle of rods. A
bundle of rods.
Uh this one over there, a serpent with
its tail in its mouth. That one over
there, the allseeing eye in a triangle.
Interesting symbolism. This one's
fascinating. A bundle of rods. What does
that mean? Those were fasci fasci.
You see the Roman uh proconsul.
He took a bundle of rods fasci and he
took them upon the mount and if he was
accepted as the leader of all he put a
wreath around it
and he was all powerful and in command
all control through the power of one
man.
It's called fascism.
Fasci fascism. If you think of Adolf
Hitler,
fascism.
If you think of Mussolini, all power in
one man. He was called the fuger.
Is that right? Okay. And that is the
system of control. Now, human rights,
what has that got to do with fascism?
Isn't that kind of interesting? I would
say it's kind of interesting. But we'll
we'll leave it for another lecture.
The first charter of human of rights uh
to nations was actually declared by
Cyrus the Great.
In the Persian culture,
there was this great fundamental
principle, good thoughts, good words,
good deeds. Cyrus the Great. Good
thoughts, good words, good deeds.
and his uh manifest went like this. When
my soldiers in great numbers peacefully
entered Babylon, I did not allow anyone
to terrorize the people.
I kept in view the needs of people and
all its sanctuaries to promote their
well-being.
Freed all the slaves. Isn't it
interesting that Napoleon freed all the
slavery and he ended religious
suppression and all these things? I put
an end to their misfortune and slavery.
That was quite a good manifest. And I
mean, human rights look pretty good.
We read on in the great controversy.
Century after century, the blood of
saints had been shed. She talks about
the valdenzas, the albbeenzers,
and she talks about the Protestants who
were slaughtered and much of it by the
power of France.
This is the Inquisition and the tools of
the Inquisition. The axe that chopped
off the head. Then uh instruments of
terrible torture. And they were mainly
tortured for heresy. Now what's the
definition of heresy? Let's look in
article heresy page 440. Greek heresus
choice.
Deciding for oneself what one shall
believe and practice. That's heresy. So
deciding for yourself or was in this
time period of 1,260 days
was an act of heresy was a sin
punishable by death. That's pretty sad,
isn't it? So taking away the conscience
of man setting up a power. Now here
we're going to have some very
interesting things happening. These were
some of the instruments they used.
These were for example tongs that opened
up and you put hot coals in them and
then you sort of modified the person who
you were interrogating with these hot
coals. These here are ankle guards or
ankle clamps. And you'll notice the pins
in them that when they were screwed
tight they went right into the bone. I
mean these people were pretty serious
about what they did. This particular
instrument was still used by General
Franco in the 1970s.
This is a pretty mean instrument. This
is one where they put it around your
neck and then they start screwing that
screw in there. Not very nice thing to
do. Stocks, of course, thumb screws.
This instrument was particularly nasty.
They would hoist you up with your hands
tied behind your back on a rope until
you hang upside down in the air. And
then they would tie this huge stone to
your feet and throw it off a shelf and
it would go and tear your arms out of
their sockets. These are pretty terrible
things that they did in the Inquisition.
And I know one needn't talk about these
things, but the cruelty of the system
needs to be known.
Revelation 12:11, "And they overcame him
by the blood of the lamb and by the word
of their testimony, and they loved not
their lives unto death." It's just to
give us an idea what those poor
Christians who stood for the word of God
went through sometimes because they
chose to believe it. It's pretty
horrendous, isn't it?
Pretty horrendous. And these are some of
the stakes that uh representations of
the Inquisition where people died in
their thousands, in their hundreds and
thousands. No, in their millions
because of heresas making a choice.
This is the Hugeno, French Hugeno
monument in southern Africa.
Many of the Hugenos of France fled and
they erected this monument. This
representing the Trinity and here's a
woman standing on the earth representing
the bride of God. There she sits on the
earth. She went down to Africa from
Europe. And in her one hand she has the
Bible over there and in the other hand a
chain.
She broke the chain which bound her to
Rome and fled to the far off distant
lands to Africa
where she is now being slaughtered again
but that's another story and fled to
America and far off lands to get away
from the persecuting power of the 1,260
days.
Great controversy says, "Blackest in the
black catalog of crime, most horrible
amongst the fish deeds of all dreadful
centuries was St. Bartholomew Massacre."
Wow. The king of France urged on by Rish
priests and prelates lent his sanction
to the dreadful work. A bell was placed
in the middle of the night. bell was
told and then the slaughter began and
50,000 Protestants were murdered in one
night by deception. They'd said to them,
"Let's work together in future. Let's
not fight anymore about all these
things." And the Protestants thought,
"Oh, wonderful.
A kind word from Rome. We can relax. We
can work together." And they went into
an ecommenism.
But meantime there was a plot and one
night the bell told and the unsuspecting
unguarded
died in one night. Well,
the guns of the castle of St. Angelo
gave forth joyous salute in Rome. The
the bells rg in joy. Pope Gregory
attended by his cardinals and priests
led the magnificent procession to the
church of St. Louis where the cardinal
of Lorraine chanted a tedo.
They were so pleased that in one night
they had slaughtered the French hugenos
and the pope had a medal struck. Here it
is a medal with his name on the one side
and on the other sides the word ugenoes
which means slaughter of the hugenos.
They rejoiced. Isn't this a terrible
thing that happened?
Deuteronomy 11:16 take heed to
yourselves that your heart be not
deceived deceived and you turn aside and
serve other gods and worship them. And
then the Lord's wroth be kindled against
you, and be shut up the heaven, that
there be no rain, and that the land
yield not have fruit, and lest he perish
quickly from of the good land which the
Lord giveth you.
So if you turn away from the word of
God, and you take the law of God away,
then there will be dryness, baroness.
Revelation 11:7. And when they shall
have finished their testimony, this word
of God, the beast that ascendeth out of
the bottomless pit will make war against
them, and shall overcome them and kill
them. Now, this over here, as I've said
before, was a jco bean hat. Now, what
was a jco bean hat and who controlled
the jacco beans?
Well, the founder of the Jacco beans was
a man by the name of Adam Vicehal.
Now, who was Adam Vice?
He was
a Jesuit professor of canon law. Isn't
that interesting?
So, the one who actually organized the
French Revolution, if you like, was a
Jesuit
and he was the father of Jacobinism. He
was also the founder of the Illuminati.
So a Jesuit founded the Illuminati and a
Jesuit ran Jaccoinism
which was responsible for the French
Revolution. Here is Engelstat University
where he was professor.
It's interesting that after the French
Revolution, the papacy had received a
mortal wound and became
insignificant in the eyes of many. But
in 1929, the smallest state in the world
was once again established. So here was
something that had received a wound and
now it rose again.
So in 1929, Gaspari signed the Lateran
Treaty and the Vatican states came back
into existence and the San Francisco
Chronicle said Mussolini and Gasparis
Stein historic Roman pact. The Roman
question tonight was a thing of the past
and the Vatican was at peace with Italy
in affixing the autographs to the
memorable document healing the wound.
It's like they're quoting from the
Bible.
Extreme cordiality was displayed on both
sides. Fascinating story. So, a power
seemed to have a mortal wound and then
rose again. Now, it's interesting that
it only seemed to have a mortal wound.
Deception is something that is
inexplicable sometimes.
Let me show you some of the later popes.
Here is Anthony Seya.
He was the first grandmaster of
Freemasonry in the London lodge founded
in 1717.
Remember this is the forerunner time
period uh leading up to this whole
French Revolution time. And these uh
Freemasons
stand like this with their hands on
their stomachs with their finger
pointing up. Well, the pope himself,
this is a picture of Pope Pius the 12th.
He had a a stamp printed which is square
and has masonic symbolism on it where he
stands on it like this as well. It's
interesting that the Vatican banned
Freemasonry.
But it's interesting too that if you
want something not to be pinned to you,
then you ban it
and practice it in secret. But at the
Vatican itself, the lodges abounded and
every cardinal was a member.
Interesting. even while it was banned.
Revelation chapter nine, remember it
told us, "And the fifth angel sounded,
and I saw a star fall from heaven onto
the earth, and to him was given the key
to the bottomless pit, and he opened the
bottomless pit, and there arose a smoke
out of the pit, as the smoke of a great
furnace, and the sun and the air were
darkened by reason of the smoke of the
pit." So the light that Jesus gives will
be darkened because of the smoke.
That's where it started. In Revelation
12:3, we have another beast. And there
appeared another wonder in heaven.
Behold, a great red dragon having seven
heads, 10 horns, seven crowns upon his
heads. So in Revelation chapter 9,
we have this smoke coming out. In
Revelation 11, this beast comes out of
the same bottomless pit. So it grows
this darkness into an established
kingdom
starts to grow. The other powers in
Revelation are this dragon with the
seven heads with the crowns upon his
head. We are told who he is. We're told
it's Satan who represents all the
kingdoms of the earth apparently. And we
are told in Revelation 12:9 that he is
the one who was cast out, that he is the
devil and that he deceives the whole
world. All right. And that he makes war
with a woman in white, which is the
other good church on earth that
represents the word of God. There are
other beasts in the book of Revelation.
There's the lion with the two wings,
which is an image from the book of
Daniel. In Revelation 13, we have a
beast that has the mouth of a lion. Then
there is this leopard-like beast. In
Revelation 13, these attributes are also
found. There is a bear in Daniel 7.
These attributes are also found in the
beast of Revelation 13. And then there's
a terrible bee beast that you don't know
what really what it looks like. So, it's
just an artist's impression. And it has
10 horns and that you also find in
Revelation 13. So, these beasts are all
very interesting. But they are
represented as coming out of the sea.
Okay.
Then in Revelation 13, all the
attributes of Daniel 7 are in this one
conglomerate beast that arises out of
the sea. We'll deal with them in detail.
Revelation 13 also has a beast out of
the earth
and that looks like maybe like this. I
don't know what it looked like. And in
Revelation chapter 17, you have another
beast with a woman riding on it.
Now, let's read that. 17:3. So he
carried away away in the spirit in the
wilderness and I saw a woman sitting
upon a scarlet colored beast full of the
names of blasphemy. It's against God
having seven heads and 10 horns.
And verse eight, the beast that thou
sawest was is not shall ascend out of
where?
Bottomless pits and go into pition. Aha,
that's interesting. Which other beast
came out of the bottomless pit?
the one in Revelation 11, right? That
makes war on God's people. Now, is there
a link here? Probably. And who controls
this beast that comes from this
bottomless pit? Who rides it?
A woman. A church rides it. Is it
possible you think that the political
systems on this earth are being run by a
woman and we don't really know it
because she has concealed herself in
mystery in secrecy and you don't really
see it. You don't know it but it's
actually happened. Do you think it's
possible? Do you think that this power,
this church might have used its agents
to pretend to kill her when actually
they control the world through its
agencies through the secret societies of
the world which was started by none
other than vice
who was a what?
>> A Jesuit.
Is it possible? Illuminism. What is
illuminism? Where does it lead us?
Is it possible that this war against the
word and those that represent the word,
the church, are going to come into
conflict with this new political entity
that has a new standard which is called
human rights?
Think it's possible?
Do you think so?
Wow.
You know there is one author who 150
years ago wrote on these issues and I'm
going to quote this author now but the
point is not whether this is right or
whether it's wrong it's just what was
perceived at that stage
and
compared to what the occult world said
at exactly the same time we will be
doing this we will be comparing what
this source said with what the
occultists themselves said at exactly
the same time period and we will see
something fascinating. So if you will
bear with me without further
identification I would like to read some
of these things that were seen to be
correct at that stage 150 years ago when
all these things were happening you know
the French revolution and all these
things v by a variety of images the lord
Jesus represented to John that's now in
the revelation the wicked character and
seductive influence of those who have
been distinguished for the persecution
of God's people.
God's representation of the detestable
works of the inhabitants of the ruling
powers of the world who bind themselves
into secret societies and confederies
sees not honoring the law of God should
enable the people who have the light of
truth to keep clear of these evils. H so
150 years ago already they perceived
that wow
secret societies were going to play an
important role. So to John, the wicked
character of these seductive influences
was shown by those who distinguish
themselves for the persecution of God's
people. Now who are they?
This terrible picture drawn by John is
to show how completely the powers of
earth will give themselves over to evil
and should show that those who have
received the truth how dangerous it is
to link up with secret societies or to
join them. This is fascinating stuff.
Fascinating stuff. The ruling powers of
the world who bind themselves in secret
societies and confederacies
and they will not keep the commandments
of God. They will have another standard.
Here's a text then quoted by the prophet
Isaiah which I read to you. Isaiah in
chapter 8 verse 9-13 says, "Associate
yourselves, oh ye people, and you shall
be broken in pieces." In other words,
make these confederacies behind the
scenes. Come on, plan together as a
world to overcome truth. Oh you people
and you shall be broken. Give ear and
you o of ye of far countries. Guard
yourselves and you shall be broken.
Guard yourselves and you shall be
broken. Take counsel together, it shall
come to not. Speak the word, it shall
not stand. For God is with us.
These people are saying God is with us.
We're doing the right thing. For the
Lord spoke thus to me with a strong
hand, and instructed me that I should
not walk in the way of the people,
saying, Say ye not a confederacy.
To all them to whom this people shall
say, a confederacy, neither fear ye
their fear, nor be afraid. Sanctify the
Lord of hosts himself, and let him be
your fear, and let him be your dread.
Aha. So Isaiah is predicting that the
world will confederate and say, "The
Lord is in this. We're working together
as a group and uh we're doing the right
thing and this is the best thing to do,
but they're leaving God out of it and it
will not work.
Then this writer applies this and says,
"There are those who question whether
it's right for Christians to belong to
Freemasons
and other secret societies. Let all such
consider the scriptures just quoted. If
we are Christians at all, we must be
Christians everywhere and must consider
and heed the council given to make us
Christians according to the standard of
God's word. That's fascinating. So,
isn't it important that we have a look
at what do the Freemasons actually
teach? Or maybe even more interesting,
who founded the Freemasons?
Who controls them? What do they teach?
Do they actually preach against Jesus
and the word of God? Do they make war on
the word of God? Yes or no? These are
questions we need to ask ourselves.
The uncristlikeness of the whole
confederacy will be seen in the secret
societies because they serve gods as
senseless and powerless to bless as the
gods of the Hindus. Interesting.
Those who stand under the bloodstained
banner of Prince Emanuel cannot be
united with Freemasons or any other oriz
secret organization.
Christ is not divided. I agree with
that.
None can be bound up with them and be
free men before God.
Wow. Interesting. Christians must sever
every tie that bind them to the secret
orders that are not under the control of
God.
We cannot belong to secret societies.
This was written 150 years ago. And then
one thing I do know, those who remain in
connection to them will be burned up
with the bundles of tears.
Interesting statements. Satanic agencies
are in every city busily organizing into
parties those opposed to the law of God.
We cannot afford to be off our God. And
then one of the plans of the secret
societies is to form gigantic
monopolies. Gigantic monopolies will be
formed. A few men will combined to grasp
all the means to be obtained in certain
lines of business. Do we see that today?
By the way, do we see gigantic
monopolies being formed forcing the
little man right out of industry so that
you will be subjected to their power?
Yes or no? And if you do not do their
bidding, you will not be able to
prosper. Do we see mega mergers? Yes or
no? You cannot open a newspaper today
without reading about mega mergers.
Right or wrong? It sounds good, but do
you know that your freedom is being
eroded piece by piece until you are
nothing better than a slave?
And if you should dare open your mouth,
well, we'll take your job away and your
industry, and you will not be able to
buy or sell. Trade unions will be one of
the agencies that will bring upon this
earth a time of trouble such as not been
since the world began.
People don't believe that. I believe it.
I have had the unfortunate experience of
standing on the other side of trade
unions when they go berserk. Have you've
ever seen that? It's kind of scary. In
Africa, where I live, trade unions are
very powerful.
And trade union sounds like a good
thing. And it's of course guaranteed by
human rights to have trade unions
because you are allowed to fight for
your rights.
But think about it. If the cake is X big
and I fight for a bigger slice,
what does that do to the slice of my
neighbor?
It makes his slice smaller. Right or
wrong? Am I loving my neighbor as myself
when I make his slice smaller so that
mine can become bigger? Yes or no? I
don't think so. And what if it comes to
the point to where you do not want to
slice up the slice?
Well, then you just take your slice.
I've stood on the other side of this.
I've had my ribs broken by trade
unionists.
They were using the universities to
bring their points across to
governments. They declared a boycott of
all university classes and students were
deprived of their education. That means
that the student can miss a whole year
having paid for his tuition and then
lose everything.
So the university decreed classes go on.
So I was the professor. I said classes
go on. And then the trade union caught
us with a class in progress. And I went
and stood in front of the doors and I
said, "Sorry, you cannot go in here.
It's I who gave permission to the
students to be taught in there. I'm
responsible, not them." And then they
started crushing me and they broke my
ribs. And the riot police were all
around and they did they lift a finger?
No. I have proof of this. I was on the
front page of every newspaper in that
country
and uh nothing happened. The students
didn't get their way. They then left.
Fortunately, for some reason they left.
Maybe there is power in the power of
prayer. They went to another place and
they smashed everything including the
poor students. Beat them up terribly. My
students escaped that day by the grace
of God. I've stood in a building where
trade unions were negotiating for
something that was not in the power of
those who they were negotiating with to
give. And so they started rhythmically
smashing against the building as only
Africans can do. And this whole glass
building exploded. Unbelievable. came
down like a shower of glass
and uh terrible things. The destruction
that you see one of the agencies to
bring about the time of trouble. The
lane labor unions are not from God.
Those who bind themselves together with
secret societies stay away from them.
This was written many years ago in
Revelation 11:15.
And the seventh angel sounded, and there
were great voices in heaven, saying,
"The kingdoms of this world have become
the kingdoms of our lords, and of his
Christ, and he shall reign forever and
ever. And the four and 20 elders which
sat before God in on their seats fell
upon their faces and worshiped God,
saying, We give thee thanks, O Lord God
Almighty, which art and was and art to
come, because thou has taken to thee thy
great power and has reigned.
So the good news is that in spite of
this power
that starts off first in Revelation
chapter 9, opening up the pits of hell
to bring about doctrines in the world
which darken the light and bring
darkness over the earth
grows eventually through history. By the
time we get to the time of the French
Revolution,
the pits of hell are opened up again and
a power arises
which is to become a universal political
power which will be controlled by a
woman, by a church which will replace
the word of God
and substitute it with its own standard.
its own ea. Does that make sense? And it
looks good on paper, but actually
violates every principle
of the word of God. Every principle of
the ten commandments is violated. And it
is difficult to see because it looks so
good. But as we continue with the
lectures, you will see that this is
really the case. If you take just the
first commandment which says, "I am the
Lord your God, you shall have no other
gods beside me."
Well, there were countries that honored
that or whatever. If you're going to
have a universal
freeforall with everybody accepted, that
would have to go. In fact, it would have
to then say, "You will have all other
gods besides me." Right or wrong, you
will have to tolerate idolatry
or else you're in trouble. When it comes
to blasphemy,
isn't it fascinating that when you
switch on the television, only one god
is blasphemed. Have you noticed that
>> only one god is blasphemed? None of the
others. This I always find very
fascinating. I want to write to the
Human Rights Commission and say, you
know, in the interest of fairness and
equality, should not all gods be equally
blasphemed? Couldn't you spread it
around a little bit in the interest of
fairness? I wonder how they would react.
I wonder how the Muslim world would
react
if that was done that was that is being
done to Jesus Christ on the television
every single day. I wonder how they
would react if the same was done in
terms of their religion or the Buddhist
religion or the Hindu religion or any
other religion on the face of the earth
if we wanted equality of everyone.
What about the fifth commandment? Honor
your father and your mother. No, the
children today have to be re-educated to
other standards to become citizens of
the world. Which means that they must
stop honoring their father and mother
and start honoring the system. Did they
do that in communism?
What did they do in communism when the
children wanted to cling to the norms of
the parents? What did they do to them?
They took them away and re-educated
them. They taught them not to honor
their father and their mother. Isn't
that sad? Thou shalt not kill.
Wow. Thou shalt not commit adultery.
Thou shalt not bring false testimony.
Are these things being tolerated? Of
course.
Jesus will one day invite everyone into
his kingdom. In his kingdom there will
be righteousness and truth and there
will be no more lie. The standards will
be the standards that he has set and
that apply to everything. And the
nations were angry.
And thy wroth is come and the time of
the dead that they should be judged and
that thou should give reward unto the
servants, the prophets, and to the
saints and them that fear thy name small
and great. and should destroy them which
destroy the earth. Isn't that
interesting?
And the temple of God was opened in
heaven where in Revelation chapter 11.
And there was seen in his temple the ark
of the testament.
Where is Jesus?
In which chamber?
>> In the most holy. Wow. We have moved
from a time of ministration in the first
chamber to ministration in the second
chamber which is judgment.
And the ark of the testimony, the ten
commandments are the universal standard
of what is right and what is wrong.
There's no doubt about that.
And we see that testimony. And this
means time is up.
And there were lightnings and voices and
thunderings and an earthquake and great
hail. This is the story of the last
plague on earth and the kingdom of God
becomes the kingdom of earth as well. So
Jesus the great high priest is seen in
front of the ark of the testimony. That
is the true standard, not the ea
controlled by a woman. And no matter how
many stalk like birds, unclean spirits
elevate the standard for the world to
accept, it's contrary to the word of
God.
As we saw up to now,
this church is defined. Unfortunately,
it's the one that rules for 1,260
days. It is the church of the Middle
Ages. It is the Roman church. And I
cannot change it. I was one myself. And
I'm so grateful for the word of God for
having shown me these things.
And behind it all, behind this French
Revolution and all of these, we see the
agencies of this church. We see Jesuit
agencies behind it all. And we've seen
that secret societies, because
everything is shrouded in mystery, will
bring about the changes which will make
none and void the word of God.
So, in the next lectures,
we're going to go behind the scenes and
open up some facts to see if this really
is so. But even if it is so, which I
assume is so, Jesus is in control and
he's permitted us to see all these
things. And he is the officiating high
priest. He is the king of kings. He will
come again in glory. And no matter how
much darkness comes out of the
bottomless pit, Jesus is in control and
there's nothing to fear. Cling to him
and nobody will be lost. Thank you.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
Heat.